christina aguilera speaks out in support
of britney spears
following the baby one more time
singer's powerful statements during her
conservatorship hearing last week
well thank you so much sweetie christina
took to twitter on monday
sharing this throwback snap and writing
in part
quote it is unacceptable that any woman
or
human wanting to be in control of their
own destiny
might not be allowed to live life as
they wish to be silenced ignored
bullied or denied support by those close
to you
is the most depleting devastating and
demeaning thing
imaginable as for britney's claim that
she has an iud to prevent
pregnancy and is not allowed to remove
it in hopes of having a child
christina wrote every woman must have
the right to her own body
her own reproductive system her own
privacy
her own space and her own happiness
and while the grammy winner who starred
on the mickey mouse club with britney
from 1993 to 1994
admitted that she is not behind the
closed doors she added quote
the conviction and desperation of this
plea for freedom
leads me to believe that this person i
once knew has been
living without compassion or decency
from those in control
and the dirty singer concluded her post
saying that her heart goes out to
brittany
and quote she deserves all the true love
and support in the world
[Applause]
last wednesday the 39-year-old performer
appeared remotely to address a los
angeles judge for the latest hearing on
her conservatorship
during her testimony she called out her
father jamie spears
and alleged that the conservatorship
holds her back from living her life
this is very important that she's
decided to speak out now and i think
she's doing it because
basically she's come to a head and she
needs to figure out what she's going to
do about this conservatorship
and she thinks this is the best way to
get her point across
i think it's a very big deal that she's
speaking out and she has told the court
she wants her voice heard britney
expressed that she would like nothing
more than to quote
end the conservatorship without being
evaluated
and would like to regain control of her
life she also shared a slew of shocking
allegations
against both her father and her team she
was very passionate that it should end
and that she had been wronged and abused
et spoke with the director of the
unauthorized documentary the new york
times presents framing britney spears
samantha stark she was sitting front row
for brittany's testimony
she also said her management she felt
forced by her management to perform and
go on tours and that she
would be punished if she didn't she
mentioned
visits with her kids and her boyfriend
could be taken away she also said
that things like that she wanted to get
married and
have a baby but that she had an iud in
and
she said that they she felt like they
wouldn't take her to the doctor to get
it taken out
following britney's testimony the
attorney for her father said in a
statement to the judge
quote he is sorry to see his daughter
suffering and in so much
pain mr spears loves his daughter and
misses her very much
several stars took to social media after
the hearing to speak out in brittany's
defense
how proud of her are you oh completely
couldn't be more to be more proud
justin timberlake who dated the pop star
from 1998 to 2002
shared his thoughts on twitter writing
in part quote
after what we saw today we should all be
supporting britney at this time
lena dunham kiki palmer ashley tisdale
khloe kardashian mariah carey andy cohen
and more also lent their support how
about
we all start listening to britney
spears nikki and kathy hilton were
guests on andy's late night talk show
watch what happens live that night they
also chimed in with
their two cents she should know we
believe her
yeah yeah free brittany such a sweet
girl
and a good girl as for paris hilton
she sent her longtime friend some love
during a dj set
in las vegas
in may paris praised brittany while
chatting with e.t
i love her i was actually texting with
her last week and
she's just so sweet and down to earth
and
really an amazing woman and i'm just so
proud of her
and last week she tweeted her support
for brit writing quote
11-11 make-a-wish
free brittany